don't come and finally come five days
later than planned
those are the sri lankan government's
directions to the chinese survey vessel
the yuan wang five
and despite india raising concerns over
security they were dismissed by the
ship's captain as it arrived in sri
lanka's southern port of hambantota on
tuesday morning
the vessel mainly carries out ocean
mapping and monitoring we're also
supporting the aerospace construction of
china
but analysts describe the ship
differently saying it's an advanced
technology vessel that can monitor
satellite rocket and intercontinental
ballistic missile launchers
china's ambassador in colombo also
seemed to praise srilakka standing up to
new delhi
even though you have experienced some
different rough weather this time on the
indian ocean the porch call of huang wan
five to hambantota has come through it
shows not only your courage tenacity and
invincibility but also the deep-rooted
unfading and enduring friendship between
our two countries
for days india has opposed the presence
of the ship saying it could spy on its
activities
and sri lanka's government asked china
to hold off until now
we are but a small country in the middle
of the ocean while india by looking
after its own interests must also look
at its role as a global power
sri lanka is facing the worst economic
crisis in living memory
and relies heavily on india for support
but china has also made major
investments in the country as part of
its belt and road initiative
a dispute over the role of the vessel
behind me has been at the heart of a
diplomatic tussle between two asian
giants caught in the middle sri lanka
has had a delicate balancing act to
ensure it keeps both onside miner
david brewster is a senior research
fellow at the national security college
of canberra he says the ship is capable
of being used for spying
i think this is really quite significant
it's
um this vessel while uh
called a satellite tracking vessel
almost certainly has a range of
intelligence
gathering uh capabilities and those uh
that intelligence gathering is very much
aimed at india that's why the vessel is
in the region
and
so the indians have uh very significant
concerns uh about that they see uh see
cv says sri lanka really assisting china
uh in these endeavors
and um
this they see this as really a slap in
the face
uh particularly given the amount of
emergency assistance that india has
given to sri lanka in recent months as
part uh
to as part of the sri lankan
economic crisis so
i think for both china and india it's
really quite a significant event well
there's obviously a lot going on
behind the scenes
sri lanka is desperately trying to
renegotiate
a large amount of loans with china while
also
negotiating
an imf assistance package and here we
see the the conjunction of all of that
and the chinese really flexing their
muscles
about this so it's clear that this uh
this vessel doesn't need to dock in sri
lanka it could probably dock in a range
of other ports in in the region but it
was very important
from the chinese perspective
that they forced this this visit through
and
clearly they were using
the uh the outstanding debts from sri
lanka as leverage against the sri lankan
government